well hello you guys were so fun in this
is it third time's a charm
um well the third time hopefully will be
the charm that'll be the next one this
will be the second time but yeah yeah we
we do enjoy we do enjoy making a movie
together yeah is there one part that is
your least favorite of working together
again does he get on your nerves
well in this movie we don't have many
scenes together so i couldn't get on our
nerves too much yeah
i'm thinking okay sorry you know i'm
like you know what it's fine
for yourself
yeah we we're waiting
just wait
you'll get the dirt in the next one
i truly have uh
nothing bad to say about chris chris is
uh if anything he's a pain in the butt
in the best possible way in the sense of
like how much he cares
about the script the story the dialogue
how much
he wants to just like
he is
you have to stop him asking questions
you have to stop him from
suggesting new ideas it's like it's a
non-stop but in the best way possible
because you want
your partner
and if i were a director at the same
thing you want your actor to be that
involved and and
care so much yeah so yeah
that's the only moment like i'll take it
yeah someone tell him please stop
[Laughter]
yeah
you are really good at playing a villain
really good at playing a villain i feel
like that might be the next i don't know
i know the superhero thing but can we
just
is there another angle we can go now
yeah listen i love playing people who
are unapologetically themselves you know
and then sometimes that comes in the
form of villains villains oftentimes are
are unbound by these social norms and
you know propriety and so lloyd
certainly fits the bill yeah i know you
had a bone to pick with et canada once
because we posted well we tweeted oh are
you trying to canada well do i have beef
with you no it wasn't me you know that
photo you posted it you had us you had a
mustache
i'm very confused i don't know what it
was a photo what was it refresh my
memory um we were tweeting about him in
a new project you were tweeting about me
for something and of all the thousands
of photos you could have chosen they
chose like the worst photo of me humanly
possible right it was free i'm pretty
sure so they just used whatever was
accessible
do you have the one that you chose do
you have it you don't have in the card
it's no i
didn't i was scared to bring it in here
i do have the print that's the joke
in the
hallways my whole thing is you had the
stash in this film
so is this that do you like the stash do
you not like what do you want from us i
mean the stash in this movie i think is
a little more groomed you you took that
photo from the play right the the
broadway show yeah
no that was violence you guys chose
violence
i'll never forgive you for it it wasn't
me
you did it okay
and i will not forgive you
all right the villain i saw him in the
flesh and i feel hot okay um sparring
against ryan what was that like i
actually loved watching that yeah it's
great i mean he's he's so fantastic he's
he's incredibly committed he's
uh wonderfully giving actor and uh
you know i think when you have these
scenes where you have
uh
to really kind of spend everything you
have you want to make sure that everyone
around you is doing the same thing
otherwise you can walk away feeling a
little salty